jimsy is a travel adventure squirrel and
the giant Chinese noodle a novel I did
write in eight hours and eight minutes
no planning page 53 stop do not marry
this turkey from the Chinese noodle
walls did comes these words and then a
slicing of the noodle wall did happen
and jumping into the noodle cave with
tim c and Duke was some you will make
sugar putts Oh while so crazy how did
this occur nobody does no but it did
happen does many things I'm here and I
did hear your story and when you did
touch your tattoo I did awake from my
hunting trip and zend it ride Santa's
sleigh to arrive here very fest to stop
your vetting time with dukes of turkey
because I love you Tim Z hard likes a
pavements I'm here now with you and I am
Samuel and you are Tim see and let us
marry said Samuel so yes Phil Collins he
is here and his very large drum set is
also here and he does start to play his
drums bing bang sticks tech crash bang
say the drums and Phil is very much
happy and watch out here is coming a hug
of love shall I continue one more ok uh
oh yeah and he does get a tattoo of phil
collins and phil collins this old man
body on his chest and the words phil
collins is also a hot tottie on his leg
and then he is ready for marrying of
phil collins and tim she is so confusion
and what is happening I love you Samuel
and so awkward with dukes a turkey who
is angry and or what shall I do and I am
a lost lost lost lost lost lost lost
lost lost lost lost lost lost lost lost
squirrel who is crying hot and what
shall I do with my life and oh no boom
you